today's episode of two cents is all
about the ladies Oh should I go no you
should listen okay ladies time for a
little real talk
women report feeling high or
overwhelming levels of financial stress
twice as often as men why is that there
are two major reasons the first is
compensation the gender pay gap is real
and it is nasty in 1988 American women
made an average of 66% of what a man
would make in an equivalent position and
today that number is up to 80 percent
during that same period women have had
to shoulder more financial burden with
dual income households on the rise and
42 percent of today's mothers with
children under 18 being the primary or
sole breadwinner and this has lifelong
implications the less you're paid the
less you're contributing to Social
Security which means we have to be
setting aside more of our already
smaller paychecks for retirement and
that doesn't even take into account the
fact that we tend to live longer which
is hardly a plus if you're spending
those extra few years and abject poverty
the second reason is confidence or a
lack thereof in my research and
professional experience I have seen
women consistently undervalue their
money management skills even when they
tend to make the right decisions in a
University of Cambridge study just 42
percent of female business owners said
their business is prospering compared to
62 percent of males despite the fact
that the female run businesses reported
higher average profits less than half of
women said they'd be comfortable
consulting a financial professional and
only 20 percent said they discussed
money with friends or family that
doesn't leave a lot of opportunities to
increase your skill set
shrinking that wage gap is a long-term
collective battle but you have more
personal control over your financial
confidence and it starts with learning
why women are actually
rate with money women are better
investors only 43% of women said they
were confident in their investments but
a 2014 study showed that women outpace
equivalent male investors returns by 12%
why because women tend to be more
conservative investors and think of
their financial picture more
holistically men on the other hand are
more focused on achieving certain rates
of return which drives them to buy and
sell more often and be more likely to
pop on trendy bandwagons like Tesla and
Bitcoin this impatience means that men
are 25% more likely to lose money on
their investments and the same thing
seems to be true in the bond market
during the past 15 years women run fixed
income funds outperformed the average
returns of those run by men women manage
debt better although we typically earn
less there is evidence that we are
better at managing personal debt back in
2015 Experian came out with a study that
showed on average women had slightly
higher credit scores than men and men
tended to have more consumer debt on the
books according to one study in the
developing world women had a 97% payback
rate on micro loans extended to them and
were far more likely to reinvest back in
their businesses rather than blow it on
luxuries like men tended to women make
excellent business owners women now
account for 40% of new entrepreneurs in
the United States and many of them are
killing it according to a Harvard
Business Review study women tend to
excel at influencing others to support
their vision and managing operations
behind the scenes especially when
resources are limited we're pretty used
to making the most of what we've got and
we are gaining ground approximately 40
percent of us working women now out earn
their husbands and over the next decade
women will control two-thirds of all
consumer wealth in the United States
with many female baby boomers
experiencing a double inheritance from
parents and their spouse we're also
getting more educated in 2013 women earn
56 percent of all bachelor's degrees and
60% of all master's degrees and we hold
the keys to the greatest economic tool
on earth 75% of women reported that they
were the primary shoppers for their
households which means we are making the
decisions that determine which products
and services prosper obviously this is a
topic I'm passionate about and a short
video simply can't cover all the
problems and possibilities that women
face but if I can leave you with one
thing it is this financial empowerment
will not be given to you it must be
claimed that so let's stretch out our
hands ladies do it for yourself and the
ones closest to you they're following
your lead whether you realize it or not
and that's our and that's my one set
you
[Music]